저희 애도 어느 날 이렇게 거울을 보고 있다가 와가지고
제 얼굴을 이렇게 보고 딸인데 막 화를 냅니다 짜증을 내고
아빠 닮았다고 미안하다고 미안하다고 했고요
오랜만에 좀 알포인트처럼 만들어서
내용 한번 볼까요?
전재준 씨의 사랑을 가져왔습니다
전재준 씨 글로리에서
전재준 씨는 87년생이네요 생각보다 나이가 좀 적어
어린 놈 치고는 싸가지가 없는데
이분이 이제 꽤 특이한 캐릭터였어요
더 글로리에서
악인인데 나쁜 놈인데
분명히 나쁜 놈인데 약간 밉지가 않아
그리고 어떻게 보면 진정한 사랑을 보여주거든요
상대 여성도 그냥 소모품으로 보고
자기보다 약한 사람한테 굉장히 함부로 대하는 이 사람이
자기 친딸 나랑 같이 큰 아이도 아니고
지금 남의 딸로 크고 있는 애인데
내 친자라는 걸 알게 됐을 때
표현하는 그 헌신적인 사랑
동훈이는 뭘 사랑하나?
동훈이는 사랑하나?
사랑이 없다가 나중에 사랑을 찾게 되는구나
그래서 이걸 보면서
우리가 이거를 뭐 말도 안 되는 얘기야 라고 안 하는 게
저도 그런 생각까지는 안 들었어요
아 그럴 수 있지
전재준이라는 소시오패스도
자기 자식한테 저럴 수 있겠다
라는 생각이 들 정도로
어떤 자식에 대한 사랑이 있는데
그거를 현대인만 그랬냐
옛날 사람부터 그랬습니다
이효석이 이제 메밀꽃 필 무렵
수능 보면 이거 다 보죠
내용 다 아시죠
아 한컴 타자 연습도 했어요
이효석 씨가 원래 일본 유학파입니다
한국에서 처음에는 조금
이제 약간 사회문제 다루고 이런 걸 쓰다가
일본이 좀 강압적으로 한국을 통치하기 시작하니까
약간 이런 토속적이고 이쪽으로 가거든요
그 중에 대표작이 메밀꽃 필 무렵인 거죠
제목도 보면 메밀꽃 필 무렵
다 한글이네
뭐냐면 장돌뱅이
장 돌아다니면서 물건 파는 상인인데
허생원이 있습니다
허생원이 돌아다니다가
동희라는 약간 젊은 장돌뱅이 하나를 동행하게 되죠
대화로 가는 길에
가면서 동희랑 있는 한 하루 이틀 사이
그 사이에 있었던 일들을 그린 건데
허생원이 장돌뱅이다 보니까 결혼을 못 했어요
허생원이 여기서 보면은 이제 그
천연두를 알아서 곰보로 나오거든요
얼겄다 이렇게 나오는데
그러다 보니까 결혼을 못 했는데
젊은 시절에 성서방네
처녀하고 몰래박간에서 뭐가 있었대요
그 얘기를 합니다
그래서 이제 아 좋았다
뭐 이분 언젠가 한번 만날 수 있으면 좋겠다
뭐 이렇게 했는데
동희가 일종의 사생아다
내가 그런 얘기를 합니다
아버지가 누군지 모른다
그래서 그때부터 허생원이
안 그래도 동희한테 조금 눈길이 계속 가거든요
동희가 그 장터에서 약간 주몽가?
뭐 희롱할 때 막 화가 납니다
저런 놈이 엄청 막 소리 지르고 막 그러거든요
그러다가 이제 점점 퍼즐이 맞춰지는 거죠
그리고 여기서 결정적으로
허생원이 점점 그 얘기를 들으면서
쟤가 내 아이일 수도 있겠다라는 생각을 하는데
동희가 마지막에
나귀 타고 가나?
이제 그 나귀 탈 때 채찍은 아니고
막대기 같은 걸 왼손으로 잡는 걸 봅니다
나도 왼손잡이거든
거의 약간 확신 같은 걸 가지면서
다음에는 그 어머니가 제천에 있어요
어머니가 제천에서 주막하고 있다고 그랬나
그래서 이제 제천으로 가자 하고 끝나는데
그러네 내용은 좀 어버이날 특집은 좀 안 맞는 거 같기도 하네
부모의 재결합 스토리니깐 괜찮지 않을까?
이 그 시적뿐인데
표현 묘사가 되게 뛰어나죠
보시면 여기 읽어보시면 기억날 거예요
이거 수능에 거의 맨날 나오는 겁니다
공감각적 시상 이래가지고
짐승 같은 달의 숨소리
달이 숨소리를 낼 리가 없죠
시각인데 시각에 청각화
손에 잡힐 듯이 여기는 이제 촉각화까지 간 거죠
그래서 이거 시험 굉장히 많이 나왔던 거 같은데
요즘은 모르겠어요
이 경우에는 허생원이 약간 그럴 듯한
그런 거 같아 라는 생각만으로
동의한테 정이 가고 있는 거죠
그래서 무슨 말 할지 아시겠죠?
그 어떤 부모의 자식에 대한 사랑이 뭐랄까
이해하기 좀 힘들 정도로 끌리는 지점들이 있다
왜냐? 유전자 때문에 그렇습니다
우리 다 알고 있지만 옛날에는 그게 뭐 핏줄
뭐 어떤 천륜 이렇게 생각했는데
밝혀졌죠 DNA 때문이라고
유전자 이 유전을 그대로 형질을 또는 이 유전을
우리 아랫세대한테 전달하는 게 우리의...
존재 이유다라고 이제 알게 됐죠 우리가
진짜 신기한 게 저희 애도
어느 날 이렇게 거울 보고 있다가 와 가지고
제 얼굴을 이렇게 보고
딸인데 막 화를 냅니다
짜증내고 아빠 닮았다고
미안하다고 미안하다고 했고요
그 전부 다 저를 닮은 건 아닌데
신기하게 이제 그 첫째 딸들은 아빠를 좀 많이 닮더라고
첫째 아들은 좀 엄마를 많이 닮고
DNA라는 게 있었고 DNA도 사실 좀 상대적으로...
좀 근래에 어떤 밝혀진 거예요
1953년 돼서야 어떤 이중 나선 구조가
이렇게 될 것 같다라고 학계에서 결론이 났고
그전에는 발견은 1869년에 발견했습니다 DNA
이 단백질을 그런데 얘가 너무 약간 심플해가지고 상대적으로
더 복잡한 단백질로 유전이 전달될 거라고 생각했는데
이제 점점 지금은 다 알고 있죠
예전에는 막 DNA 관련해서 소설도 많이 나오고
엄마도 많이 나오는데 요즘은 DNA 다 하니까 안 나오죠
심지어 SF에서도 DNA 얘기는 안 해요 이제
AI 얘기만 할 뿐이지
다 아는데 아직 인간은 못 만들죠
못 만드는 게 아니고 아마 안 만드는 거에 더 가까울 거예요
가능할 수도 있는데
그래서 이게 철학에도 어떤 인간에 대한 이해도
영향을 준 게 이기적 유전자 책이죠
이게 76년 책입니다
50년 전 책인데 여전히 우리한테 막대한 영향을 주고 있죠
그전에 인간은 어떤 영적인 존재고
어떤 감정이 있고 심장이 있고 영혼이 있을 거라고 생각했어요
그런데 DNA도 밝혀지고 과학이 발달하다 보니까
인간이 그냥 단백질로 이루어진 거고 의식도 영혼이 있는 게 아니고
뇌가 학습해서 반응하는 것뿐이고
그리고 뭐 너가 이제 유전자도
너가 중요한 게 아니고 유전자를 퍼뜨리기 위한 생존 기계
유전자를 번식하기 위한 통로일 뿐이다 라는 게
밝혀졌다 보니까 철학 쪽에서도
리처드 동킨스 이 양반이 행동학자예요
동물 행동학자예요 진화 생물학자고
그런데 이분이 생물을 어떤 철학적으로 인간을 이렇게 규정한 거죠
진화의 핵심은 개체나 종이 아니고 유전자고
유전자가 진정한 어떤 핵심이고
개체나 종은 그걸 이어주기 위한 기계의 어떤 과정일 뿐이다
허무하죠 엄청
배양체에 불과하다라는 거잖아요
프로메테우스 에일리언 보면 거인이 오셔서
지구에 오셔서 독약을 먹고 자살을 합니다
그래서 이 몸이 녹아서 DNA가 이 원시 지구에 들어가서
거기서 인간이 진화하는 걸로 나오거든요
이걸 보고서 아무도 말도 안 되네 이러지 않습니다
우리는 그만큼 유전적인 어떤 이 메커니즘에
우리는 동의하고 있는 거예요
사실은 이게 맞는지 안 맞는지 저는 잘 모르겠어요
어쩌면 유전자가 아닐 수도 있거든요
만약에 영혼의 존재가 밝혀진다면
영혼을 유지하기 위한 그냥 그릇에 불과하다
이렇게 될 수도 있죠
알포인트는 항상 되게 피곤한 날 꿈같다고요
제가 피곤한 상태에서 만들어서 그런가
그럴 수도 있습니다
뭔가 명료하지 않죠 명징하지 않아요
사실 그게 진실이거든요
우리가 알고 있다는 게 그렇게 명료한 게 별로 없어요
심지어 우리가 주식시장 어떻게 될지 모르니까
맨날 모여 앉아서 이러고 있는 거잖아요
근데 저는 저는 아직은 영혼의 존재를 부정하고 있지는 않아요
왜냐하면
저는 원래 그렇지 않았는데
저는 이제 우리 아이를 낳아서 아이 눈을 보고 있으면
이게 뭔가 물질적인 거는 넘어서는 뭐가 있다고 생각이 들 때가 있어요
지금은 그렇지 않습니다
지금 우리 아이는 자본주의의 괴물이 됐기 때문에
괴물까지는 아니지만 돈을 알아버리면 그 선한 눈빛이 없는데
우리 아이가 한참 귀여웠고 정말 순수해 보일 때는
눈을 보고 있으면 뭔가 그 안에 뭐가 있는 거 같아
나는 이제 잃어버린 뭐가 있는 거 같아
이런 생각이 들 때가 있습니다
그래서 이런 생각을 하죠
대중문화에서 나온 거긴 한데
신과 함께 처음에 보면
최태현 씨가 젊은 시절에 어머니가 머리가 안 좋으셨을 거예요
베개로 동생을 위해서 동생하고 내가 살아야 되니까
어머니를 존속살해 하려고 합니다
염라대왕이 너 존속살해 하려고 한 죄가 있어 라고 하는데
사자인데 디펜스하는 변호사 격인 거죠
변호사가 어머니가 몰랐으니까 아무도 피해자는 없다라고 하는데
사실 여기 영화에서 보면 어머니가 알고 있습니다
어머니가 자신을 아들이 자기를 죽이려고 하는 걸
의식이 있었어요 깨 있었어
그런데 저항하지 않고 그냥 죽으려고 하는 거죠
물론 어떤 사례가 발생하지는 않습니다
최태현이 반성하고 바로 도망 나와서
그래서 도망 나와서 집에 못 들어가는 거예요
그런 생각을 품었다는 죄책감 때문에
그런데 사실은 저도 경험적으로
사실 부모님들이 자기 자식들한테 해주는 거 보면 거의 조건이 없잖아요
자식이 나한테 뭐 해줘서 해주는 게 아니거든요
그리고 저도 부모가 되니까 우리 아이한테 해주는 게 조건이 없어요
그냥 보면 해주고 싶고 가끔은 아닌 경우도 있습니다
하지만 대부분의 경우는 뭘 해주고 싶고
그런데 이게 아까 이기적인 유전자를 통해서도 설명이 되는 거죠
왜냐하면 내 유전자를 가진 유일한 존재고
이 유전자를 건너 다른 쪽으로 스프레드 하려면 얘가 보존돼야 되니까
그러니까 얘를 적극적으로 최우선적으로 보호하려고 하니까
나 자신도 버리는 거죠
왜냐하면 얘가 더 어리고 나는 이제 점점 죽어가는 존재니까
그래서 나를 버린다 뭐 이렇게 설명하더라고요 이기적인 유전자에서
저도 그럴 것 같아요
아이가 위험하다면 생각하지 않고 그런 선택을 하겠죠
케이스가 많습니다 글로벌리 한국도 되게 많고
익사하면서도 아이를 위로 이렇게 버티다가 돌아가시는 분들도 있고
잔인한 거죠 사실은 그런 선택을 해야 된다는 게
그리고 이거를 학습시키는 것도 저는 안 좋다고 생각합니다
그런 어떤 생명을 바꿀 수 있는 가치가 있는 건 아니라서
그래서 권장하지는 않습니다
그래서 조금 제가 그동안 이해가 안 됐던 게 좀 이해됐습니다
주식시장에 한국 주식시장에 있었던 많은 일들이 이해가 됐어요
아 그래요 그들도 부모였어 그들도 부모니까
뭔가 리스크는 있죠 리스크는 있었는데 그런 것들을 해 오셨다
광고 우리 광고 주기는 하는데 다 했으니까 다 했으니까
똑같은 공평한 겁니다
대기업 집단 다 했어요 그게 과거니까
제가 누구를 비난하는 게 아니라 그랬었다 그죠
한국 시장이 그래서 좀 힘들었어요
미국같이 자식들한테 안 물려주고 다 기부하는 데가 아니잖아요 한국은
자식을 사랑하니까 그래서 자식을 사랑하니까
이런 일들이 합병도 있었고 물적 분할도 있었고
쪼개기 상장도 있었고 지배구조 개편안도 있었고
쪼개기 상장은 조금 자식하고는 상관없기는 하겠지만
넓게 보면 관련이 있었겠죠
그리고 포괄적 주식 교환도 있었고 저사주 마법도 있었고 상속 이슈도 있고
낮은 배당료 이런 것도 있었습니다
왜냐하면 과거 얘기 아닙니까 과거 얘기고
편집되겠다 여긴 그죠 어쨌든
DNA가 우리가 그렇게 돼 있고 또 한국 사람들이 자식을 사랑해야 된다는 마음이 되게 많다 보니까
그런 일들이 많았어요 그래서 코스피가 그동안 일했던 거예요
코스피는 전 진짜 수많은 시련의 기록이라고 생각합니다
코스피에 투자한다는 건 정말 자식을 사랑해서 투자한다는 거죠
자식이 투자했지만 자식한테 버림받거나 집안을 풍부 확산 내거나 그런 리스크를 감내하고 하는 게 코스피였어요
자식이 투자한다는 건 정말 자식을 사랑해서 투자한다는 거죠
참 힘든 시장이었죠
그래서 부모의 사랑과 함께한 또는 수많은 부모의 눈물과 함께한 코스피를 나눠서 보도록 하겠습니다
1983년에 코스피가 처음 산출 공표됐는데 굉장히 힘든 시기를 보내다가 요즘엔 굉장히 이 각도 뭐야 와 장난 아니죠
우리나라가
85년에 코스피가
131위였네요 88년 올림픽하면서 89년 4월에 1000포인트를 처음으로 찍습니다
그러다가 빠지고 94년에 또 좀 넘었다가 다시 빠지고 IMF를 맞습니다
그래서 IMF 때 300포인트까지 빠졌다 그러다가 다시 1000포인트 찍고 99년에 닷컴버블을 같이 맞습니다
그래서 좀 빠졌다가 다시 500까지 갔다가 2005년에 가서야 다시 1000을 가
1989년에 찍은 그 포인트를 그래서 이때부터 코스피를 박스피로 불리기 시작하죠
계속 이 박스권에서만 있으니까 2005년쯤에 월드컵 하고 나서 약간 3, 4, 5 되면서 되게 좋아지는데
왜냐하면 그때 세계화가 본격적으로 커지기 시작하고 중국 특수를 누려요
중국에서 중간제도 많이 사가고 중국에 올해 수출을 많이 하면서 1000을 돌파하죠
그래서 밀레니엄 좋았는데 문제는 2007년 2008년 좋다가 2008년에 금융위기를 맞습니다
우리는 아니었는데 미국이었는데 같이 빠지죠
그래서 2008년 10월에 892까지 빠져요
빠졌다가
다시 2011년에 2200포인트까지 올라갑니다
금융위기 나고 급하게 빠졌다가 급하게 올라가요
그리고 2011년부터 다시 디디 시작합니다 옆으로
이거는 글로벌리 마찬가지였는데
2016년까지 켜요
그래서 우리나라 이때 제가 2014년에 해치펀드 가거든요
왜냐하면 이때는 해치펀드가 제일 잘하는 친구들입니다
왜냐하면 횡보하니까 방향성이 안 나오면 해치펀드가 제일 잘해요
2017년부터 쭉 올라가죠
이때가 제가 말씀드린 52주 맨날 손실냈던
그 중에서 가장 잘하는 친구들입니다
52주예요
이때부터 제 인생이 꼬이기 시작했어요
힘들어졌어요
그리고 2018년 1월까지 또 올라가
2018년에도 뷰가 굉장히 좋았거든요
2018년 1월에 모두가 더 이상 안 떨어진다고
더 올라간다고 할 때부터 빠집니다
그래서 2019년에 기고
제가 2018년 이때 중국에 있었어요
중국에서 무슨 컨퍼런스가 있었어요
전세기 기관 투자자들이 모인 해치펀드도 많이 모이고
거기서 컨퍼런스 할 때 보팅을 했습니다
2018년에 해치펀드가 많이 모이고
에는 S&P500이 어디가 될 거냐
대부분 다 25% 상승한다고 찍었어요
그때부터 빠졌어요
참 시장이 더 이상 희망을 버렸을 때가 거기가 바닥이고
모두가 다 절대 안 빠진다고 한 때가 꼭 지더라고요
보면 신기하게도
사후적인 얘기입니다
이게 19년까지고 괜찮아지다가 코로나를 맞죠
이게 코스 P니까 1439
지금 7500인데
코로나 때 1439까지
갑니다
급반등하죠
그래서 3200까지 가요
이때가 21년까지
이때가 동학개미운동 나오고
이때 한번 맛을 보시죠
급등의 맛을
그러면서 퇴사자가 급증하면서
내가 투자의 신이라고 생각하면서
그게 2021년 6월 30일에 돈을 몰아넣기 시작합니다
그러다가 쭉 빠지는 거죠
이때 기억나시죠
지금 이거 보시는 분 중에서 굉장히 많이 기억나실 거예요
2021년 6월부터 2021년 6월까지
2023년 초까지 쭉 빠지죠
그러다 2023년 2024년 기다가
2025년 4월이 저점이었고
거의 1년이에요
지금 5월이니까
1년 동안 올라간 게 지금 시장입니다
쭉쭉 올라가죠 쭉쭉
그리고 2025년
아까 이거 좀 겹칩니다 시기가
2025년 4월에 저점을 찍고
2025년 5월부터 쭉 올라간 게 지금입니다
이게 오늘까지에요
왜냐 사실 왜냐라고 저희가 물을 수도 있는데
이 대선 요거를 부정할 수 없고
그 전에 이제 리버레이션 데이라고
갑자기 2025년 4월에 트럼프가 관세를 부과한 것도 있긴 하지만
우리가 대선이 5월이었어요
불안감이 내부에 있었죠
그런데 어쨌든 선거가 끝나고 나서 정권이 들어서니까
불안감이 좀 적었고
마침 그 정권이 굉장히 강력한 주식시장 부양 의지를 드러냈어요
그러다 보니까 억눌린 수요가 올라갔고
거기에 플러스 미국이 중국하고 싸우면서
중국 제조업을 막아버렸어
그럼 제조업 잘하는 건가요?
우리나라가 좀 팔기 시작했고
게다가 또 미국이 갑자기 배가 없네
우리가 이러면서 배를 만들어 줘 라고 했고
게다가 또 우크라이나 러시아랑 전쟁하면서
방산을 좀 잘 만드니까
탄 이런 거 엄청 많이 잘 만들고
게다가 거기에 플러스 마지막으로 반도체까지
메모리 반도체
반도체가 붙으면서 지금 날아가고 있는 거죠
그래서 뭔가 약간 음덕을 쌓은 게
이제 와서 받는다는 느낌이랄까
그리고 코스피가 지금 이렇게 반등하기 전까지는
코스피를 지켜온 사람들이 있어요
지켜온 사람들이 있고
그 욕을 먹어가면서 코스피를 지켰고
코스피를 운영했고
또 코스피에 대한 어떤 애정을
계속 가지고 있었던 사람들이 있죠
그게 20대나 30대는 아닐 겁니다
지금 뉴스에서 나듯이
60대 여성이 제일 수익률이 좋다 라고 하는
물론 그분들이 뭘 지키거나
누굴 지키겠다고 있는 건 아닌 건 알아요
하지만
어쨌든 결과적으로는 그분들이 한국 자본시장에서
계속 있었던 거죠
그게 어떤 욕심의 발로였던
그리고 우리 어렸을 때는 대부분 이르시니까
저희 아버지나 어머님들 이르시니까
약간 빈정되기도 했고
주식 그거 맨날 하면 맨날 잃는다고
하지만 그것들이 쌓이고 쌓이고 쌓여서 있다가
이제 어떤 시기를 맞아서 지금 올라가고 있다고
저는 보여집니다
그리고 아까 보여 드렸잖아요
정에서 부정에서 또는 모정에서
발로 된 거긴 하지만
자본시장이 주식이 못 올라가게 가로막고 있던
여러 가지 어떤 제도적 허점이라든가
관행들 이런 것들을
우리 윗세대가 너무 많이 경험한 거야
그러니까 도저히 이거는 못 참겠는 거죠
그래서 그거에 대한 개선 요구도 많았고
정치권이 그걸 받아들였고
그래서 내부적으로도
그런 개선의 가능성도 높아진 상황에서
외부적 호재까지 와서
지금 주식이 올라가고 있다
제가 이게 누가 올컷이든가
뭐 그런 얘기가 아니고
드라크뮬러도 그렇게 얘기했습니다
주식이 올라가는 건
너가 돈을 버는 건
시대가 그런 거인 가능성이 높다
너가 잘하는 게 아니고
나는 맨날 그 죽는 자리를 도망쳐 다니다 보니까
돈을 번 거다
이렇게 얘기 하시거든요
그래서 지금쯤 내가 주식천재다
이렇게 생각하시는 분이 있을 수도 있습니다
돈 많이 버시는 분들도 있을 수 있어요
한 2, 3년 전에 코인 하시던 분들이
그런 생각 많이 하셨습니다
그리고
너무 자신감에 차서
퇴사하시는 분들도 꽤 있을 텐데
물론 한 50억 벌었으면 퇴사하셔도 됩니다
하지만 지금 상승하고 있는 조건들
갑자기 반도체 사이클이 꺾이거나
내적 정치적 동력이 꺼지거나
또는 더 무섭게 미국이랑 중국이랑 화해하거나
그러면 많이 달라질 수 있어요
이게 이제 국민연금 규모입니다
자산이 지금 1,600조 원이에요
그래서 글로벌리 보면
단일연금으로는 TOP3인가 TOP4예요
그래서 국민연금이 국내 투자를 그렇게 많이 하진 않지만
이게 어떤 상징적으로
한국에 부가 쌓인 자본이 쌓인
한국에 6.25 끝나고 나서는
한국에 자본이랄 게 거의 없었거든요
돈이 거의 없었어요
근데 그거를 미국에서 빌려오든
또는 어떻게든 자본을 모아서 여기까지 온 거거든요
저는 뭐 민족주의자도 아니고
국뽕 이런 거 되게 싫어하는
저는 리버럴이니까
근데 이건 인정하지 않을 수가 없어요
한국전쟁 이후로
한국에 어쨌든 잘 살기 위해서 노력했던 것들이
부로 이렇게 쌓였고
그 과정에서 되게 불합리한 것들도 되게 많습니다
사실은
그리고 비판한 지점도 많지만
그걸 다 싸잡아서
다 나쁘다고 볼 수는 없는 거고
그것들이 쌓이고 쌓이고 쌓여서
저는 지금의 어떤 주식시장의 화랑이 온 게 아닌가라고 생각해요
그래서 어느 정도 인정을 해야 된다
어느 정도 아니고 많이 인정을 해야 된다
어쩌면 우리
저는 이제 약간 저도 자식세대라고 볼 수 있죠
우리 전쟁도 경험하시고
또는 산업화 과정에서
아까 연말정산 얘기했잖아요
산업화 과정에서는 그거 쓸 수가 없었어요
쓰는 거 소비를 되게 억제하고
자본을 축적했으니까
그렇게 해서 뭐 포항제철 만들고
그런 것들이 어떻게 보면 비효율적일 수도 있겠지만
반도체도 사실은 우리가 국가적으로 지원한 겁니다
지금도 하고 있고
그래서 그런 것들을 지금 향유하고 있는 시기인 거죠.
그래서 저는 요즘에 어르신들이 더 수익률이 좋다니까
어떻게 보면 좋기도 하고
마찬가지로 어르신들도 아까 봤잖아요
부모의 사랑 내려줘야 된다
돈도 좀 내려주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
세금도 좀
물론 이제 젊다고 다 돈을 줘야 되는 건 아니지만
세금도 좀 하고
지금 이 얘기가 그냥 좋게 좋게 이런 얘기인 거예요
왜냐하면 요즘에 뭔가 이제 포모도 좀 있으시고
그런 것 같더라고요
그리고 일부 제가 느끼기에는 굉장히 거칠게 기존 분들
약간 주의해야 되는 거 아니냐라고 얘기하시는 분들을 거칠게 공격하시는 분들도 있고
그럴 정도로 저희가 힘들지 않잖아요
그리고 윗세대들에 대한 존중도 좀 있었으면 좋겠고
그리고 윗세대 분들도 좀 젊은 친구들을 이해하려고 좀 노력해 주시고
무조건 너네가 틀렸다
너네가 게으르다 이렇게 얘기하면 안 될 것 같습니다
그리고 남성 여성도
잘 지냈으면 좋겠고
채널 안에서도 잘 지내셨으면 좋겠고
유튜버들끼리도 잘 지냈으면 좋겠습니다
가정의 달이니까 가정의 달이고
어버이날이니까 따뜻하게 보냈으면 좋겠고요
내용보다는 제가 지금 느끼고 있는 어떤 그런 생각
감정 이걸 좀 전달해 드리고 싶었어요
5월 달에는 조금 있으면 따뜻해질 텐데
조금 날카로움을 내려놓고 서로 이해하고 그랬으면 좋겠어요
그렇죠 그래도 되잖아요 주식시장이 이렇게 좋은데
그리고 가정의 달이니까 오늘 부모님한테 꼭 어버이날이니까
대부분 요즘엔 찾아뵙고 이런 거 없죠
그렇죠 전화라도 했으면 좋겠습니다
부모님들도 전화 오면
젊은 친구들이 그 마지막 말미에 전화 통화 마지막에 화를 낼 때가 있습니다
왜냐하면 길어져서 그런 거예요
요즘 젊은 친구들은 길게 통화 안 하거든요
그리고 통화 안 하고 텍스트가 더 익숙해요
그러니까 어머니도 어머니 아버지도 전화 오면 3분 안에 끊는 걸로
돈을 달라 이렇게 말씀하시는 게 좋은 것 같습니다
그리고 돈을 못 벌고 있는 아들이 전화하면 돈을 보내 주시면 좋을 것 같고요
돈이 제일 좋은 선물입니다
호불호 없고요
머니코믹스도 여러분들 덕분에 유지되고 있는 거고
어버이까지는 아니지만 항상 감사한 마음을 가지고 있습니다
좀 전해졌으면 좋겠고요
그래서 오늘 어버이날 맞아서 트레이딩룸 끝내기로 하고요
사실은 오늘 제 생일입니다
제가 5월 8일에 태어났거든요 그래서
좋은 날이 됐으면 좋겠습니다
그러면 편안한 주말 되시고요
다음 주에 뵙겠습니다 감사합니다